welcome to this video playing EU 707
from Israel okay played an audio he said
maybe I can try this for a change this
gains a bit not a lot but a bit and
strength after his success already being
played by black so this feels like or
maybe start with this feels like I'm
fairly comfortable position okay here i
can't play Queen f32 to h3 this is an
interesting interesting setup okay it's
not in any way reacting let's see rather
than it's so it's already bit dangerous
with g4 g5g for or Bishop g5 is also
interesting ok I'll start with G form
okay so g5 probably okay interesting i
can play rook g11 possibility all right
on i don't really like to take it this
loses a tempo 90 x takes on table on the
bishop maybe root g one we can take on d
too but i don't know if this is so so
much of a problem with King Gandhi to it
would at least open up this this Bishop
2h7 I really want to play f3 here ok so
now I have this idea yeah I really don't
know why do you need to play this in a
second yeah giving up all your counter
play here ok let's see many
possibilities now taking on age seven g6
mmm g6 probably not working yet ok i can
i can drop it back for the moment and
improve and prove that the whole thing
Luke g 4-h form is also quite
interesting yeah I'll do that
okay um show page 7 or not
okay check let's do this takes this
rogue age 49 f a Droog h8 mate or any
night move okay Jade mate Bishop g5 rook
h7s also win I don't don't see a defense
f6 I take h7 this will not be survived
you can try for a counter play taking on
here taking on c3 and Queen B 6 but then
probably just look see one
it's always the funny thing then
sometimes they play this in 30 seconds
and I almost lost and then when they're
obviously lost they start to to use up
all that time black resins probably
probably correctly plus 13 yeah yeah
it's just you need to if I mean I'm not
saying that this is super great what I'm
playing it just it's just obviously
quite dangerous for the King yeah
everything's pointed to the king and you
can really spend just just a moment to
think and here in fact I could have
taken on 87 already interesting Jack
computer points this out immediately I
don't understand it ah because it six
hangs oh ok this is very strong very
strong yeah that's totally winning you
cannot take because of needing two moves
here this is the trick ok yeah well I
made the same mistake and taking here in
one second but gala it keeps my my
strong attacking position intact yeah I
think this is still a win plus 3 and I
can still take h7 I simply didn't
appreciate that the queen is only six
okay whether the funny thing is it's
working all the time I can can take on
h7 all the time now this is third plus
five so I played it in a somewhat
clinical way just not not taking that
even here g6 was no not the g63 six
years for once not working because now
I'm not only six here I blocked my own
you know yeah it's really if black is
playing this early six Bishop f4 can can
be an interesting alternative especially
the black is playing in the somewhat
passive manner what can often build up
an interesting attacking formation like
that that's really in there that's
really dangerous black needs to be a
very precise and defending and as you as
you have seen that it can be dangerous
really quickly TM hear that that's
already already tricky you know the hear
that also was this I didn't like it on
principle but this was also good of
course okay thanks for watching